[Music]
so
[Music]
hello everyone thanks for joining us
today uh we're just gonna give
another one two minutes just so that
everybody can stream it
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
hi good afternoon
thanks everyone for joining today we'll
be starting soon
alright good afternoon everyone i'm
huying i'm from the design singapore
council and i will be your host for
today
thank you for joining us today at the
launch of the business value of design
program
organized by the design singapore
council the national agency for design
in singapore
in partnership with leading business
strategy and design firm mckinsey design
today we'll start with some welcome
remarks from mr mark we from the design
singapore council
following this we will hear from
mckinsey on the business value of design
research and how
they've shown that design can be a key
factor in driving commercial success
this will be followed by an introduction
to the business value of design program
which will help you take action to
deepen design behaviors within your
organization
and drive and drive better business
outcomes
during this webinar there will be two
zoom polls we encourage you to
participate in these
and share your thoughts with us we will
then end the webinar with a q a session
joining us in the q and a session will
be mr draxio from design singapore
and mr adrian de ballier from salad
stock before we proceed i would like to
highlight a few housekeeping notes
firstly please note that this session
will be recorded during this webinar
your audio will also be muted
however we welcome questions throughout
the session please keep your questions
coming in
through the zoom q a function when
posting a question
please identify yourself and indicate if
you'd like a specific
panelist to address your question if you
are facing technical issues
please feel free to reach out to us
through the zoom chat function
here's a quick recap of where the
various zoom functions can be found
this is on the bottom bar of your window
now that everyone has familiarized
themselves
let's start off this afternoon's program
with some opening remarks by mr marquis
executive director of the design
singapore council mark is a design
thinking pioneer in singapore
who has designed award-winning
innovative experiences
for the public and private sectors as a
design veteran with wide industry
connections
mark has brought the work of the council
to the attention of global design
leaders
please welcome mr mark we
hi mark i think you're muted at the
moment
oh okay can you hear me yeah that's
working fine
great thank you thanks and thanks
everyone for taking the time to join us
here today
um this webinar actually marks the
launch of our
new business value of design program or
bvod
in short we are really excited to share
more about this partnership with
mckinsey design
and how it may benefit you and your
company
but before we jump into that i'd like to
share a little bit more about
who we are and why we do what we do
design singapore council was established
in uh 2003
and since the economic review committee
identified design as a key
differentiating competency for
businesses
we are proud to be the national agency
in singapore
championing the growth of the design
sector here and our vision is to help
singapore become an innovation driven
economy
and a lovable city by design by 2025.
you may be wondering what is design
actually and how can businesses
benefit from it simply put design is
about user centricity
it's about understanding a user's needs
and problems
and then being able to create and
deliver effective solutions to address
them
and it is only by combining user user
desirability
technical feasibility and business
viability that you can achieve
innovation for your business and that's
what we believe
as a council we believe that design is a
key enabler to helping companies uncover
new opportunities
by placing customers first and driving
profitable and desirable human-centered
innovation
and this is why we have actually been
actively working to support companies
to embed design within their business
practices
and as part of our recently launched
design for business initiative
we worked with several companies to
leverage design to address their
business challenges
for example plo a provider of premium
bidding to the hospitality industry was
looking to create a direct to consumer
strategy
that offers a more premium experience in
asia
while photohub a one-stop professional
imaging solutions
provider was keen to develop a new
experience offering
alongside their product sales we have
supported them to work with design
consultancies
to frame their problems clearly from a
human
user's perspective and identify
opportunities and solutions they can
implement to drive
business growth and we are adding to our
suite of design for business initiatives
with the bvod program for the first time
ever
through their extensive research
mckinsey was able to show that great
design
is strongly correlated with great
business performance
and their data-driven approach to
helping companies
uncovering business opportunities
through design
and coupled with mckenzie's strengths
and business consulting
mckinsey design our natural partner of
choice for this program
essentially through the bvod program we
want to help singapore companies
navigate the current challenging
economic climate and realize new
business opportunities
through a data-backed but human-centered
approach
our sincere hope at this is that this
program will
not only help you understand your design
capabilities today
but also enable you to imagine or
re-imagine your aspirations for tomorrow
and identify actionable next steps to
reach these goals
so thank you and i hope you enjoy the
rest the rest of this webinar
and join us really on this new program
all right thank you mark next i would
like to invite mr jeff gelvin
senior partner and leader of mckinsey
design in asia to share about mckinsey
design's groundbreaking research into
the business value of design
and the impact that it can deliver for
businesses based in mckinsey's tokyo
office
jeff also leads mckinsey's fintech
efforts in the region
and brings vast experience working with
startups incumbents
private equity and venture capital
investors in areas such as investment
strategy and execution
as well as design digital and analytics
jeff please thank you very much
for those of you who mostly know
mckinsey as a consulting firm
um i also i just want to start by
highlighting we're also by any measure
a leading design firm globally you know
as the as the slide here points out
you know over the last several years
we've both hired a number of world-class
designers
and also acquired leading design firms
such as lunar
you know vera day and others around the
world and are really working
across leading organizations on design
thinking and overall design strategy so
we like to say you know there's the
mckinsey that everybody knows or used to
know
and there's a new mckinsey we're also
building that's doing many exciting
things in the area of design
and maybe as we kick off the discussion
today we can just start with a quick
poll on the topic of design
how well do you understand your
customers because as you will all know
about design thinking it's all
fundamentally about
understanding your customers i'll be
curious to see where the results come
out
so top you know 80 to 100 percent how uh
sorry is it do you understand your
customers extremely well
pretty well we could do better would
love to hear the results
i'll just wait to see the
answer pretty well
that's not bad it's pretty consistent
also with what we've seen we've run this
poll in many other organizations
interestingly most companies feel they
know their customers
pretty well and sometimes on a good day
extremely
well the interesting thing is when we
run the exact
same survey with the customers
themselves
they almost always tend to come out with
the 20 to 40 percent we need to do
better
or even worse and i think leading
organizations
if we can turn to the next slide are
starting to realize
that the only way they're going to
address this gap
between their self-perception and what
customers really think
is by implementing better design or
thinking throughout the organization
so you can read for yourself some of the
examples here from
pepsi and intuit nike and dell about how
those leading organizations are really
trying to take
you know design thinking to the next
level to to make sure they can
understand their customers
and create great products and services
and in fact that the urgency of
understanding customers and
and using design is even more important
in today's covet environment
i think many organizations if not most
have been caught a little flat-footed
obviously by the pandemic and as
customers have had to change their own
ways of interacting with companies of
living frankly
um companies have also had to respond
you know nimbly to to work with them so
this urgency of using design
thinking has become even more important
during this pandemic
mckinsey has put together a mckinsey
design index
we've also done a lot of other research
to see if design is just a i'll say
an interesting way of engaging with
customers or if it also impacts the
bottom line
and one thing we've found throughout our
research including in this rigorous
uh design index is that actually you
know
good design is good for the bottom line
top quartile
design firms according to our research
really do
outperform their peers across many
you know top and bottom line metrics and
these results
are true across sectors business
functions
enterprise types etc so there really is
some
some rigor to our belief that you know
better design means better business
and to be clear design isn't simply it's
a bit like i do a lot of work in the
broadly defined digital space it isn't
just a slogan
it's not just a feeling about you know
uh
drawing it's not a feeling it's not
setting up a design department
using catch phrases or or launching a
single new product
it really is like those of you who've
done an agile transformation or other
things
you know diffusing design thinking
throughout the organization and really
working in new
fundamentally new ways that are more
customer centric
and as i said we've launched a design
index to help
organizations better understand where
they stand today
relative to peers some of my colleagues
and others will talk about this a little
bit more
later on but i just want to highlight
this for you here
as i as i wrap up
great design leads to great business
performance and we have the numbers to
show it
regardless of your company's goal your
business is ultimately centered around
your customers and users
and this is what design is all about
user centricity in your business
strategy
processes and products and services at
design singapore council
we believe that design is key to helping
uncover new business opportunities
and drive profitable and desirable human
centered innovation
and design is not an abstract concept
for the first time mckinsey design has
successfully quantified
business improvements from design and
that's why
we have partnered them on the business
value of design program
an extensive five-year study by mckinsey
design found that high-performing
companies in design
achieved high revenue and total returns
to shareholders
by 32 and 56 respectively competitive
peers
built on mckinsey design's research the
business value of design
program helps your company understand
your design capabilities today
reimagine your aspirations for tomorrow
and identify actionable next steps
forward
the bvod program is structured into two
phases
in the first phase assess and reflect
your company will assess
its current design performance and learn
about the key design
behaviors most strongly correlated with
improved business performance
[Music]
in the next aspire and act phase you
will re-imagine the possibilities for an
upcoming business plan
and using insights gathered from your
company's assessment
develop an action plan to drive better
performance
[Music]
design is not an intangible concept it
is a key business enabler that looks
into every organization's ability to
harness data
and analytics about their business how
they shape
cross-functional talents helps them
focus on delivering holistic user
experience
and the need to for continuous iteration
as they bring new products and services
to market
we got introduced to mckinsey or this
program
by design singapore and then mckinsey
walked us through the mdi
framework that they use and that really
sort of helped us benchmark
ourselves compared to other peers in the
industry
the design i think will be a huge
enabler to our growth
design needs to be fundamental to any
organization and i think that thinking
process that mindset that you have
through that growth trajectory that
you're about to embark on i think
especially for smes
since we are small and we need to be
quite nimble i think it's important to
align
everyone to make sure that we can scale
up that we can
grow internationally and and continue
with that growth mindset
and and really having the design-centric
approach to
any kind of future projects that we
embark on
today i've learned that as a company we
need to
open our mindset to not just the daily
tasks that's given but also in terms of
how we can move forward together
and also think about the customers
element first
and how we design and integrate together
as a whole
i think one of the main benefits for the
mdi
is to put that design thinking to the
forefront
of our activities so where as it was
something that was sort of always on our
minds
this sort of pushes it in a structural
way
one of the things that we've learned to
stay agile is
to develop a common platform lingo
or model that we can use with the team
in order to track
consumer feedback in a continuous manner
[Music]
all right thank you jeff for sharing
with us about mckinsey design
and the research on the business value
of design i hope all of you enjoyed the
video and showed us a little bit into
what the program experience is like and
what you can get out of the makenzie
design index
next i would like to invite miss dany
lit senior partner and co-leader of
mckinsey and companies
social healthcare and public sector
practice in asia
to share about the impact of the
covet-19 pandemic on businesses
and the role that design can play in the
recovery formerly the managing partner
of mckinsey's
singapore office yani brings deep
experience in helping government
entities and companies
design and implement major
transformation and economic development
programs
let's welcome jenny
thank you very much huying let me start
first by perhaps putting the elephant uh
in the room that we've all lived with
over 2020 uh which is covet 19.
right um as we all know this has really
created
an incredible double imperative uh for
our times
it at the heart is very much a concern
for lives as we work through
this virus but it has also
disproportionately affected many of our
livelihoods
right and the chart here just shows it
and i know that uh many of us are still
working from home
staying safe and hoping that uh the good
progress we've made as a nation
continues particularly as vaccines
become
available if i could go to the next
slide please
and similar to jeff i'd like to just get
a quick
poll of how has your business
changed as a result of covet 19.
has it been fundamental has there been
much change some change little change
or no change if we can just put the poll
up quickly please
and i'd just love to get a pulse check
we'll give everyone
sort of 30-40 seconds just to respond to
this
just give it a little bit time and then
the poor results should come up shortly
very interesting um if we compare this
and just so in case people can't see it
on the screen the majority of you are
seeing
much change uh there's nearly 20
of you saying quite fundamental change
uh and some of you very fortunately
uh only a little bit of change i would
say these results
are mirror and in some cases are perhaps
a little bit
worse than uh the rest of the world and
what we're seeing with our clients
globally which is not a surprise because
singapore in particular as a small
country
it's particularly exposed uh to the
global impact
we are part of a globalized world and as
a result of that
as tom friedman would say you know when
someone sneezes in another country
we catch a call along with many others
uh in the region if you could go to the
next
slide please as we all think about
sort of the post-covet world uh we're
encouraging leaders to
really think across five horizons many
of you will already
earlier this year have had to deal with
the resolve and resilience phases
where it's about shoring up the
operations of our
individual companies i'm hoping that
many of you are
in the return phase and hopefully well
into
the return phase to get uh business uh
back to
to normal i know this varies
tremendously depending on what sector
you're in
but as we look into 2021 we hope that
companies will have the opportunity
to move into what we call the reimagine
and the reform
phase and it is this is in this
reimagined
phase that we do believe that design
can be incredibly valuable
it is at this time we believe an
opportunity
to really reflect on the changing world
of customer expectations
uh to deal with the rise of accelerated
digitalization
and really translate some of that into
what does that mean for new customer
needs
what does that mean for new products and
services and the way
uh for us as individual companies to
deliver
uh what we do and so we do think that
it's a particularly opportune time
that the bvod program is being launched
we hope that it can be very much part of
your reimagine plan as we go into
2021 and maybe with that
let me turn it to matt to talk a little
bit more about
what exactly is the bvod
thank you jenny for the view and to the
challenges that business leaders must
address in today's environment and of
course the role that design
can play uh next i would like to invite
matt
uh like denise so matt is
an expert associate partner at mackenzie
design
and he will share a little bit about the
business value of design program
let's work on that great thanks
and good afternoon everybody thanks for
your time this afternoon
so we've we've had an introduction to
the business value design we've put it
into a singapore context and we've shown
a video
of what it feels like to participate in
the program
and what i'd like to do over the next
five minutes or so is just make sure
that you
you understand the elements of the
program so i only have
five pages to walk through but it's the
intent is to describe
the process before i
describe the process i wanted to set up
how this
program came about so since the business
value of design
study was published several years ago
mckinsey has been helping companies all
over the world
to use the mckinsey design index to help
understand their design maturity and
then to use that
to provide initiatives on what best
practice looks like
and so we've been doing this for for
hundreds of companies
and the wonderful opportunity with
singapore government
design singapore is to scale this
program across a country so it's the
first of its kind and it's very exciting
and what we've needed to do is to
reassemble the elements of the program
such that we can
use it across multiple companies at the
same time we have this field and forum
approach
and so the forum part is a bit like a
classroom where you you learn things
and you come back together to reflect on
what you've done and the field part is
where you go away and do homework
and so we've struck this um great
balance of
thinking about the needs of singapore
companies and how to do this at scale
and we've come up with the
the program so this is really designed
from the ground up
so as kelly mentioned during the video
there are two parts to the program so
you begin with
assess and reflect and so to begin with
we
you do the mckinsey design index
self-assessment
and then you will come along to the
business value of design forum
to unpack your results
like jeff showed in his slides he showed
an ipad essentially filling out a report
and then a
fairly detailed um
[Music]
report of the design actions so this is
the kind of thing that we would go to
in the business value design the next
part
is to take those those learnings from
the report and put them to work so we
have
aspire and act so we have our aspiration
exercise which is the core of the
program that we'll go into
later and then we regroup after you've
done that to the next steps forum
now so these are the the pieces and what
i'm not going to go into right now is
the
the timing so who yang will describe
that to you later on
uh but what what i'm going to do is just
drop into each of the one two three four
and just give you a feel for what those
are like
so yeah step number one to sign up and
take the
mdi this is the easiest step
so what you need to do is you need to go
to the
bvod portal and then you need to
that will allow you to sign up to the
program
and then you will input some information
and you will
take you through the mdia website where
you will take
the self-assessment so this takes
approximately
45 minutes to do it's approximately 166
questions and we would encourage
uh more than one of you at your company
to take this
so ideally you'll have a minimum of
four or five folks from your company
will will do this
and each of you when you do this
you will automatically receive a short
mdi report
which is going to tell you how um from
your
opinion your company aligns with um all
of the
the other companies in our in our
database right so this
answer will be it's quite minimal it
just gives you a percentile you're
either
fitting within the the first second
third or fourth quartile
plus how that would correlate to your
business performance
but really what we would like you to do
is to come along to the bvod forum
where you will receive the uh the full
mdi report
as was illustrated in uh jeff slides
early above
so that's the first step and it's the
easiest step
step number two is the bvod forum
and it's very likely that this will be a
virtual workshop given our own kind of
state but if for four hours
you will be understanding a lot more
about
the mdi and the origins and where it
holds true and and what best practice
really looks like
from some of our experts that will call
in
we'll then be unpacking your full mdi
report for your company
right so obviously this is something
that you'll receive
privately but you'll you'll review these
as a as a group
and we'll be able to explore you know
what what does it mean
um for your scores uh looked at across
our four themes and our 12
12 sub themes so um
often we will find um there may be some
close alignment across
some of the scores sometimes there may
be a disparate view of how your company
is performing and sometimes you'll be
clearly perform underperforming in some
areas so
this is a really um a really rich
learning experience to
to see how your company is performing in
these themes and then we're going to
teach you about the aspiration exercise
which is the next step
and how to do it so essentially this is
the the jump off point
so that's steps one and two and then you
will
decide to join in to aspire and act
so this is where you've you've done the
mdi you've had a really positive
experience
you've learned a lot about your company
from your mdi report
and you'd like to do the aspiration
exercise
and for this you'll need a a commitment
from your
your company for at least two or three
people
to more or less full-time
uh work on this so this aspiration
exercise
is the first step of your journey to a
transformation
that is infused with the knowledge of
your mdi report
and i won't go too much into the the
detail
now but what we found is that the best
success that companies have when they
embark on these transformations is that
they pick
the next product or service which is
really meaningful to them
and really get behind that new product
or service and give it as much
best practice design oxygen as possible
so step number one is to identify
um what is that uh initiative that
new product or service that you're
working on that keeps you awake at night
and you realize is you know is
the unlock to either recover um out of
your covered
situation or to take advantage of it
and then step number two is where we
further unpack your
mdi score uh and we focus on the areas
where there is
some weaknesses shall we say and um
we try we uncover what's behind
those those weaknesses and we use that
as a kickoff point to create
better practices we review these
uh steps one and two in clinic number
one uh which is where
we'll come together in our mckinsey
design experts will give you
uh one-on-one feedback around exercises
uh number one and two
and then you'll you'll learn how to do
exercises
three and four and you'll go away and
work on these so
in exercise three we figure out some
initiatives for you to focus on
uh that are in the context of your new
products and services
and then we'll be updating your business
plan with this
information uh to create a
i guess a bolder ambition and aspiration
you know being cautious we'll in our
next clinic
um we'll be doing a pre-mortem on why
this isn't going to go to plan
and this is really insightful for how to
how to get to success
and then we end the the aspiration
exercise with a celebration of your
aspiration by you creating a front page
of a fortune magazine in the future
saying what you've achieved so it's a
short two-week exercise
but we find it's very effective in
really focusing
on the uh the new product or service
that
is really important to you and infusing
into it
all of the lessons that we've learned
and best actions uh
from mdi the final piece is the next
steps forum
which is which is the now what uh forum
and what we do is we we reflect on your
your learnings
we share between the participating
companies
and what we do is we leave you with a
very prescriptive list of design actions
for areas where there is the sort of
greatest weakness
um to build into your your next step
forward
plus some options about you know which
way is is right for you to proceed from
here
so essentially we don't we don't leave
you hanging we give you options on how
to take it forward
so this is the this is the bones of the
uh
the bvod program i'd like now to hand
back to hui
ying to talk about some of the mechanics
of signing up
all right thanks matt for walking us
through the program uh so let us
let me go through how you can join us on
this program before we start with the q
a
yeah so as man i shared earlier
if you can go to the next slide please
yeah so as matt has said earlier the
business value of design there are two
phases to it
so first in the assess and reflect phase
uh you can benchmark your company's
design performance through the online
mdi assessment and then get a more
detailed understanding of the key design
behaviors that correlate to
improve financial performance now this
phase is free for companies to join
because design singapore will be funding
this in full for participating companies
next is the second espion act phase this
is where you'll work
with guidance from mckinsey to develop
an action plan to improve
and this part will also be co-funded by
design singapore so this phase will be
available to selected companies
at an exclusive rate of 2 500 per
company before gst
so to get started on the program
the online application to join the
program opens today with the launch of
the program
so keep in mind that this program is
applicable to all companies
regardless of the industry that you're
in or the company or your company's size
so within the online application form
you will be asked to nominate one to
five senior leaders of your company to
take the online
mdr assessment this is really so that
you can get a really good
view of how design how your company
works in terms of design performance and
how you've adopted
design actions and design behaviors
so there is a five-week window between
now to 31st
december where you can complete the
online assessment at your own time
so this assessment is expected to take
about 45 minutes
and upon completion you immediately
receive an overall mdi score
subsequently selected companies will be
invited to join us at the business value
of design forum this will be on 11th
january 2021
and you will get a breakdown into your
mdi score so that you can understand in
more detail
how your company is doing in terms of
design actions
and selected companies will also be
invited to join us for the aspire and
act phase so this will be in late
january to early february 2021
yeah so we hope that has been useful for
you and now let us move on to q a
so for the q a we would like to invite
mr draxio deputy executive director
at the design singapore council to join
us
along with
matt yes hi matt yeah matt from mckinsey
and jeff and dy also from mckenzie
[Music]
yeah let's just take a minute for
everyone to switch on the videos
let's see hi jeff
are you ah okay all right great
now we've got some really interesting
questions in the q a uh but let me just
start with
a simple one so we all know that kovit
is impacting businesses right now
and i suppose this question which let's
start with jax
since businesses is impacting are really
uh feeling the impact of covett right
now why is this a good time for them to
really start to embark on this kind of
design journey
when this can be something that's quite
new for them and they're committing
resources into really
making sure that their business can
survive at the moment
jax if you have any sort of things
um many businesses
is being disrupted and i think the cove
situation currently has kind of
accelerated that
um so even though a lot of businesses
are kind of
looking at how to survive this period it
is also a good time
to take a step back actually and look at
some of the
key business drivers that
could help the business pivot let them
change
or to help them adapt to the new normal
um and the thing design
and i think as everybody kind of has the
really spoken about it uh offers
a kind of user-centered approach that
could help
company better understand users and
customer needs and challenges
and with those insights they could bring
about change and re-imagine their
business
of course we understand during this
period i think time and resources
is awfully precious to many businesses
which is why
this program is designed to be contained
within a concise two to three weeks
to give you quick insights and give you
an indication of what
action that you can take to start that
reimagination journey and start your
design journey
would any of the rest of the panelists
have any view into this
hi divine i think you a mutant
um maybe i can just add to what uh jax
was saying
right um i think there are
and i think we should acknowledge there
will be some companies for whom survival
and resilience is still the primary
right and i think we must acknowledge
that uh i would say however at least
from our experience
uh 80 or so have you know gotten at
least the
the biggest crux of of cobit behind them
and we're seeing at least the ones who
are able to devote as jax was saying
even just a little bit of time
to kind of lift their heads above the
day to day
and really look forward are benefiting
disproportionately
right um you know people always say
never let a good crisis
go to waste and i think that applies
here uh as well
right and we are seeing that the ones
who are able to
will benefit in the long term and thus
we are encouraging companies
um as jax was saying for even a short
period of time
a little bit of resources to at least
give you a little bit of perspective
to move forward
yeah thanks dubai yeah so i think i
think we agree that starting small is
something that
that we should all try out and
especially for
some some of the larger transformation
journeys just taking baby steps are
really
creating evidence to convince people
along the way
so we have an interesting question from
uh someone on
q a let me just pull this up
this is from patrick so quite related to
our earlier question
how would you convince an organization
that design is crucial to change an
improvement
if they have no inkling of what design
can do or if designed to them is about
aesthetics
perhaps if jeff can give us a response
to this
sure well not to make this sound like a
plug but this is one of the reasons that
we did
the the mckinsey design index work
is to try for some of the uh i'll say
skeptical people out there
to try to show them through facts
through literally hundreds of responses
that there is a strong correlation
between doing well on design metrics
and actually performing better as a
business
because there's definitely we understand
there's a lot of skeptics out there who
do view design as
call it drawing right they think of
graphical design they think oh
it's some cartoonist or something to be
cynical but we've
definitely been able to show that really
there is real bottom line impact
throughout the organization i think
that's the simplest way
we have found to demonstrate uh the
business value of design to some of
those skeptics
yeah so i think this is something that
that we agree with as well that design
goes beyond this ethics right and it's
really about strategic thinking
and of course how your organization
behaves in terms of being iterative
being customer focused
we have another question here that is
somewhat related so
this is from an anonymous attendee but
generally
the question is how would you explain
how would you explain design thinking is
different than business strategic
consulting
uh what's on the features for of design
thinking for business planning for
example
yeah well i think just to
jump in again obviously design thinking
can very much
be a part of of consulting i mean
consulting at some level is is providing
advice and
and support to to uh to clients
but at least what i think about and it's
really it is a mindset it's just a
fundamentally
uh new way of doing things but just
being extremely customer back
in the way you think about things so
starting
always with the lens of you know how can
i better understand my customers
what do they want and how from that
first principle way of thinking
can you build products and services to
support them and can you design your
whole organization around
supporting your customers i was
previously at google as well and it was
very much the mindset they took
they wouldn't call it design thinking or
they didn't call it design thinking but
it was very much
at the heart of their way approaching i
think when you look at many leading
organizations
even if they don't explicitly refer to
these things as design
thinking this notion of being just
laser focused on what customers want
is is what it's all about
perhaps met all the jokes if you have
anything to add on today
[Music]
yeah i think this is a great question
and i would
concur with with jeff that there's
something about going back to first
principles
always and thinking about the the
customer or the user if it's within an
organization and thinking about what
you know what do they need and what
we've noticed is that if you build up an
evidence of customer or user need it's
extremely compelling
in a business environment like it is the
proof to
you know solve and continue to solve for
customers
so and i wouldn't say that um you know
strategic thinking and design thinking
can't work together um but it's
certainly you know very compelling
and it's it is driving decisions in top
performing companies now
yeah thanks mate for sharing about that
similarly we've also received some
questions about
so the ndi actually measures design
performance across
companies and we've also learned that
this is a piece of research that makes
you design has done that correlates uh
basically these design actions with
financial performance
so we're also curious uh is this also
applicable to companies which might be a
bit smaller
so not not the size of google for
example
matt have you ever some views on that
yeah
yeah so we've been talking as you can
imagine a lot about this
as we've built the business value design
program with
dsg and you know as mentioned the
the study was done using the financial
and organizational
operational data of large organizations
so
300 publicly companies and then of
course you know we're curious what
happens when you go outside those
that sort of scale um does it no longer
apply
and i think as as we've been uh helping
companies
over the last you know three years now
with this
when we're not finding every any
evidence to suggest
that these best practice activities
don't still
hold true so we haven't found anything
yet um
i mean i think as as a one example um
we saw in the in the video salad stop uh
is an sme in singapore
and you know they're they're seeing uh
benefit in their
mdi reports that are very useful to them
so it's not a big
cohort of example for you but it's one
very you know strong example of where
the mdi process has been useful for a
smaller company
thanks man yeah so of course i think the
behaviors that the mdi
highlights are really applicable to all
companies whether they're large or
they're small and across all industries
so maybe another related question to
this
this this dives a little bit into
perhaps some of the mythology around
the mckinsey design index so there is a
previous study from
this question is from marisa yeah so
there's prior research
from the design management institute
which talks about the value of larger
companies showing a return of 211
over the s p 500 but most of these
companies are multinationals
uh could you share a little bit about
how the mckinsey design index mythology
is a little bit different
and are there any differences in the
types of organizations that you looked
at
jeff i i i can answer this one partially
um so the the mckinsey
business value of design study is unique
and it's the first time
we've been given the opportunity to go
inside companies
uh to not just see their um how they
behave but also their financial
data at the same time and this is
you know revealing a much stronger
correlation
much stronger evidence um
why certain companies you know perform
better um
that happen to be very heavily invested
in design action so
i think the the difference is that the
mckinsey study
is the first of its kind to go inside
rather than
outside in
all right thank you matt for sharing a
little bit into into dermatology and of
course
this this view of outside inversus
inside out that's also quite interesting
uh it seems like this is really a look
into
basically how the organization is doing
internally and
an assessment into that and of course
through the mdi survey people can get a
quick
uh almost quantitative view into how
they're doing in terms of design
performance
uh from the inside out yeah maybe just a
comment to follow up
um probably one of the biggest takeaways
that that companies have when they
you know they take the mdi and they
understand is that
they thought so so much of what's
important is beyond the product and
service itself
um that you can't just do great design
with having you know clever people
sitting in a room doing it
you actually have to develop
infrastructure and mindsets
such that you can do it and so i think
that's quite often the takeaway is it's
not
the the thing that you need to improve
is not the product or service
it's the infrastructure to make it
possible
yes and also in a related question uh
let me direct this to jeff
so we have some questions about how
design is different than a draw
lean and all the other methods that you
hear very often or
from about and are often used in a
digital space
so if you can tell a little bit about
your views in today
well obviously all these things can work
together and are somewhat interrelated
at least the way i think about it
i mean design uh can involve many things
but fundamentally as i
tried to say before to me uh design
thinking and a design approach
is very it's bottom up and it starts
with the customer
uh and works backwards to to ensure that
um all of your products and services and
your organization
are aimed at serving the customer and
the customer's fundamental needs
and just to make it clear what i mean
and how that's different from maybe
other ways companies work i think we've
all worked with or inside organizations
where
actually the way they tend to start is
with the products and services they have
i think most organizations
naturally there's this organizational
inertia
to where you start to be very internally
focused on
okay what product do i have how can i
push this more how can i sell it more
how can i take this to a new market and
okay we've already built it in i'm
making it up in japan
let's take it to singapore um the design
thinking approach i think is more of a
methodology it's a mindset
it's a forcing mechanism to make sure
you're always understanding your
customers
and working back from them to build your
organization and
kind of serve them now there's all sorts
of other ways
to me consulting is just an umbrella uh
kind of topic of advising companies on
how to do a better job at whatever they
do
it could involve design thinking agile
to me is about
you know self-organizing
cross-functional teams
you know delivering typically technology
and products
that can go hand-in-hand with design
thinking because obviously you can start
with the understanding of the customer
and what you want to build you're then
using an agile design methodology for
agile development methodology to then
deliver it so all these things come
together and whenever you see a large
transformation or a new business build
you know you use a bunch of
tools to put it together so there's not
really any contradiction at least in my
mind
thank you for sharing that so
essentially businesses can use all of
these methods and it's really about
which one
is the most suitable for for their
particular needs and of course
uh the specific products and services
that they're trying to deliver
correct
yeah so i think adrian has just joined
us on the panel
so thanks thanks for joining us adrian
thank you hello hi hi
yeah we were just discussing a little
bit about uh design and
trial and lead methods so these i
suppose are some of the terms that
you'll be familiar with
uh since you've just joined us on the
panel perhaps if you can share a little
bit about
how design is applicable to your
business and how and your experience of
it essentially
sure um i think we've um
so we've started 11 years ago and i
think design i mean
came from a physical standpoint i guess
um
you know seven years ago when we
redesigned our stores but more recently
i think really came from a
culture mindset the way we operate um
the way we
lead projects um so i think it's it's
now just so much more multifaceted
um and i think um you know it's
it's something that is sort of ingrained
in the culture
um and i mean you still have a long way
to go especially as this sort of project
um
highlighted but um but i think it's it's
part of the journey it's part of you
know putting your customer first
part of making sure that um
that it's uh again it's just integrated
in every part of your business
thanks so i'm sure that seller stop has
also
been heavily impacted by covin and i
think we've learned a little bit about
some of the experiments that you've been
running in terms of
how to try out some new business models
etc
could you share a little bit about some
of these experi experiments and also how
perhaps design behaviors has helped you
in those
regard sure so i mean i think
historically and i mean so sort of
pre-covered
a lot of our business was brick and
mortar you know we we relied obviously a
lot of the
the office uh clusters cbd uh people
just coming down from their office
buildings and and just walking straight
into our stores so
so we didn't have to do that much
digital marketing we didn't
you know we had some online business but
um that was
more based on our own uh sort of company
direction where we're investing a lot
into technology and things like that
um but covet really accelerated it
tremendously and and
where we are today is 50 of our
businesses online
um we we've had to
really raise the bar on our online
experience i think so that's that's from
a from a design experience standpoint
that's really what we focused on
is you know how do we match the
experience in store to what uh someone
would have online
and and that's been the biggest pivot
for us you know if
it meant you know how do we reach out to
customers now working from home how do
we
get them to um click on an ad uh
that you know we're pushing out so um i
think it's it's
it's it's been fascinating to see how
we've sort of had to transform
uh both online and offline uh and how
we've even launched you know
new e-commerce channels uh how we've
launched our first
uh combined cloud kitchen so that was a
first as well that we
started in august uh so yeah we've
we've tried a lot of these things
learned a lot this year and
and again always trying to put the
customer first and trying to think of
what that
experience would be like online or
offline
thanks adrian my apologies i'm going to
quiz you a little bit here because a lot
of questions from q a
that are really interested in what
silent stock does uh so we have a
an additional question here uh so
force this is from a fan of silent stop
i have to add
so he's sharing here that the end user
experience varies from outlet to outlet
uh and what he's curious is that how do
you ensure that some of your initiatives
and processes get transferred
uh down the line from that management to
the front liners and of course across
brands and across branches
um very good question and i think that's
that's sometimes i think you do it from
um
from a just daily operational level so
you know getting feedback from the
stores um you know just
coming out of this program just one
small thing that we added to
our weekly district manager updates is
is just one column that actually
um prompts the outlet manager to give us
some feedback on on what they've
experienced from a
again a design experience standpoint uh
throughout the week so if it's
you know that the uh our ordering app
wasn't working or a delivery customer
couldn't find the pickup counter just
simple things that they observe
on the ground um we want more of that
feedback so that's on a daily basis
then obviously we take on larger
projects and you know that could mean
um let's say payment gateway integration
which allows us to
to make the whole uh payment process a
lot
a lot more frictionless um so those sort
of initiatives will be
some that we would drive from the
corporate office uh and then get
feedback from the team
and then obviously the even greater ones
where we look at
a complete redesign and that's where one
store might be built
slightly differently than another one um
because of certain things that we've
learned
and then we just kind of upgrade those
stores you know as
they come along so um it's it's a
process and and there are some
sometimes areas where there's a
disconnect
um but i think where we try to at least
um do more of the a b testing and
and and that's the beauty of i guess you
know having a greater online presence is
that we can
uh we can be a lot more nimble uh and we
can be a lot more consistent as well so
i think that merging the online offline
space is is also
going to be a challenge but that's where
now at least what what we're learning
online
um feeds into everything else that we do
offline as well
thanks again for that sharing yeah of
course this this uh
especially now in the time of covet
merging online and offline experiences
is really important and i believe this
is something
something that customers want to see as
well being able to interact with a brand
across all touch points and across all
channels
so well we've come to the end of the q a
we're running it a little bit
out of time so i'm just going to end
this with a really interesting question
from micah here
uh and i wanted to get some quick
reactions from across the panel
so very question very very simple
question
is change both positive and negative
if i have some views from you uh let's
start with diy collabs
embrace it embrace change and therefore
it is both a
positive force and they will have
negative connotations because it will
force us to have to change and that in
itself is a good thing
yeah i concur with with dui uh get used
to it
because everyone's changing if you don't
you'll be left behind
i was just going to add that i think
change is good um when changes happen
you learn right
if you know jeff's just a quick reaction
to that
yeah i agree i mean covert has taught us
that clearly um
and i think especially you know
this program in particular uh i think is
about
you know that mindset shift and and
giving companies a framework
uh to be able to change and to be able
to
look internally and and reevaluate
things and uh
and i think we just from doing this for
two weeks benefited tremendously
yeah look i totally agree change is
inevitable it kind of
accelerates and decelerates but it's
going to keep happening and i think if
you look to go back to the question
about design thinking and agile and just
digital
trends in general if you look at some of
the biggest changes in the way people
work
it's all about
having your finger on the pulse of
customers
all the time so that you understand as
soon as customers are changing their
behavior as soon as trends
are coming you understand it and then
equally importantly
you can make the changes you have an
agile organization both capital and
lowercase a
an agile organization that can move very
quickly to respond to the changes
and if you just look at who's been more
successful in the last
you know 10 20 years it is tended to be
organizations that understand their
customers
and can respond to them very quickly
that's just been the biggest
trend i've seen across across industries
thanks jeff for that i love this capital
a and also the lowercase a so these are
really important lessons that
organizations must learn right
being able to to be nimble especially in
this time of uncertainty
so thank you everyone thanks for sharing
i'll close the q a session right now
and then also to the audience thank you
very much for joining us today
we hope that this has been an insightful
and inspiring session for you
we've had many many questions in the q a
so we haven't been able to cover them
all
but we will cover them in the post event
email so please look out for that
so if you wish to revisit any of the
presentations the recording of this
session will be made available
and of course to join the business value
design program
we will send in a link in the chat
but in any case you can always reach out
to us innovation design singapore.org
if you have any further questions so
let's see we should be pulling up a qr
code
here comes the link so you can sign up
for the program at this link in the chat
it's it's just a really quick online
form and then it'll just gather some
information about
your organization and then we will
follow up with you uh
to get you on board the program so we
will also love your feedback on this
webinar please let us know what you
think
and we'll be putting up a poll to get
your feedback on this
[Music]
okay
all right
for those of you for whom this might
work a little bit easier we put up a qr
code so
this is the link to the sign up form
yeah thanks everyone for joining us
today
it's been a pleasure hosting this
webinar today with that keep well stay
safe have a great day ahead
bye everyone
you